emergency meeting on the 11th of May wow
anybody remember like that's fun anyway
um has anybody got any comments about
those or can I move them from the chair
happy to Second well for the chairman
seconded from uh
right um
it's a true record
um
Declaration of Interest
we all know what we need to build with
the Declarations of Interest
this
[Music]
oh yeah
it's an action which it was uh those
things yeah oh it's like it's obviously
a chat yeah this is the taxi feeder band
could use in the apron
um which was a way before
spoken to the state employees solicitor
and also Sean Perry who's the head of
community to take it back to the CNR
committee
um for a discussion
um so it's very short at the moment
not quite sure what it is except signage
along
all right sorry yeah
it's this use of this use of the apron
on the inside
but there are this safely concerned
raised um which is why it's like to cure
um for people just because it's the taxi
will be coming out of the eating Lane
basically so it's going to be revealed
[Music]
um
by Sean
all right okay
but for a long time since May
but back of Interest well we've done
that anyway that's fine uh agreements
involved generators part one and two is
any problems
uh urgent matters information can be
brought forward uh with the permission
of the chair of the committee
no great let's go straight on with the
taxi demand survey thank you Chris okay
thank you chair
um I just said Play It's all members
here an additional submission for this
item which was received from one of the
tax and trade
um for your consideration
[Music]
um
so if you want just a couple of minutes
to read through that we'll provide
a report
foreign
see so well I'm not you're so happy I
don't know the taxi drivers will be
happening sitting on the rank for a few
hours and not earning any money but you
know but if I present a report now let
me know afterwards
um so yeah as the commit you are aware
there is a current team description or a
place for happy place of happy marriages
so 49 plates
in line with the legislation we had to
do a demand study which needs to be
repeated every three years in order for
us to maintain the Restriction
um that was due this year
um but it has to be done by a
professional company we can't do it in
Paris it's going to be completely
independent so we employ the services of
the company license vehicle survey
they presented the report
so I it's a big long report but I've
kicked out the key aspects of it
um this survey this year we've obviously
we've had the restriction for many years
we've undertaken the surveys which have
key highlighted because no one met
demand and it's been quite a
straightforward process this year with
the impact of covid
um and lifestyle changes is a bit
different this year than the results
from previous years
so this is going to go through the main
points of the survey
the pandemic has taken away the
stability of Demands you know 40
decrease so the demand on the rank is
increased by four percent that resulted
in an Outreach passenger levels of nine
of just nine passengers per hour on
average
as a result the level of the vehicle's
service in the rank appears to have
reduced from 83 to 2019 to 64 percent
as a result of this unmet demand for
African characters now occurring more
despite the reduced overall level of
demand this could supply to the rank has
produced more than demand particularly
Saturday evenings
um despite this that as part of survey
they do a public
um survey and despite this public The
Spill
um reporting that there have been
improvements for the service and they're
happy for the service so there's no
reports from the public
um that there's any problems with with
lack of taxis
um the driver survey has also found
from the percentage that were responded
to the survey only three three of the
bad principal work is from ranks most
said they they demand provided between
10 five percent of their work so do you
know in fact they're doing other work
such as school contracts or things like
that to supplement income rather than
rely on solely that way because it's
reduced so much
um so hold on the limit retain remains
supportive across the trade and many
said it provided a better service to the
focused number of drivers in fact the
review narration allowing higher vehicle
standards and maintenance and a free
market situation would result in
um it appears that the revision of
demand allowed many more to achieve
their required level of remuneration
during the week
um compounding the lower Saturday night
demand impacts seeing even less Vehicles
active then what they sort of looks at
there because the nighttime demand has
reduced
um the main nightclubs not be able to
see the code since over one of the other
pubs that is highly used is very gently
open
um so in fact the night time demand has
dropped
so it matters vehicles on the rank is
also dropped in in line with that and it
appears to be some bio changes for the
taxi drivers as well because they want
to fit out on a Saturday night in the
old few pairs
um
and they could be could be home
um so going on from the actual survey
itself the number of hours of very low
demand has increased and much of the
unmet demand occurs at these times when
it's very hard to match supply and
demand costs effectively
however 53 of all observed passenger lay
delays occur between five o'clock
Saturday to basically two o'clock Sunday
morning
adequately service and demand
um taking all evidence into account
present at me sir this seems to be in a
relatively healthy position providing
public benefit Rising apart from the
limit policy
The New Normal does not yet seem to have
been achieved a balance between driver
operating practice and passenger demand
which leads to the industry standard
analysis to Jeff being significant
poorer Public Service yet the actual
public views suggesting that they're
generally happier that the services rule
service are a possible need to consider
higher life there and we're a reminder
to the Happy Carriage Trade that their
principal objective is serving around
even if this is at times when demand is
alone this covered both the Saturday
night period but also Sunday mornings
um at least be an honest perspective of
drivers is our focus on lifestyle
choices is probably if you can supply
fines when demand and low reducing still
needs more Vehicles active than
permanently presenting themselves
uh where where to become here there was
an unwillingness to Service Such a man
it made you get to 33 but issue more
plates or limits allow others to service
and conservative demand however it
should also be remembered that the
overall low demand such an action might
be counterproductive removing many
experienced drivers who might consider
the remuneration in an insufficient to
continue their involvement
to reiterate that is fine we will not
recommend any other action than in store
in any place not unless you can be issue
and a reminder that the hat is carry the
base of Richmond to service the public
ranks available
and it goes on to say maybe the
reopening of the main like demand
generator
could draw more drivers and improve the
overall situation but it may also be
proven to test levels of service
provided within three months of
reopening of that venue to identify if a
sufficient balance to protect the public
safety has been achieved sufficient
service to that venue is important to
ensure its future appears enhanced by
the ability of patients to get home
safely
so I think in a nutshell
um the report says although passenger
demand has significantly reduced that
result in next Capital rank
but an example of a survey it was unmet
Demand on Saturday at six o'clock on the
Saturday two people waited 20 minutes
for a cab
but they were only two people in that
one hour period to actually leave them
so if you'd have five perhaps on the
ramp at that time
only one of those parts of the battery
worked during those so it's getting that
balance and I think at the moment it's
the trade aren't able to balance that at
the moment because they don't
know when the people are going to be
there or how it's going to battle and
where it's possible to be there so yeah
it's a it's a it's an interesting
situation really yeah so going on with
recommendations of the reports
[Music]
has been a fair increase on that
um we can remind that the happy
character they do their principal
purpose is to serve as the bank
um they have suggested look at it again
when the light up reopens well we've got
no concrete evidence of it to be opening
there have been rumors that it will be
reopening
um so what I would suggested possibly
feeling in informal sort of review next
May
um in-house so we wouldn't do a full
survey because obviously that's that's
the cost
um and if we do identify any further
issues we could then take it further but
as it stands
um based on the report I think we you
know we've got sufficient evidence to
retain the limit
um the only issue is we've got two
outstanding plates at the moment of a
two-handed bat during the year which
wheelchair accessible vehicle restricted
we held them as a result of the survey
and the survey as recommended that we
issue those plates so the
recommendations basically in my report
um
there's three things to consider
actually I've got more than one bit in
the actual recommendations but the
basically there's two two issues to
consider first wherever we usually those
two accessible plates which I think we
should and the other is to retain the 49
plate limit for a third of three years
but whether we also want to do an
informal review now
have you had any applications for the
two plates we would put that out for
application we have had the tentative
inquiries okay
um but I've said we'll let you know
because
until committee approved it then
obviously
the report terms pain management through
those plates and we wouldn't add them to
issue or
[Music]
my concerns are I heard you know within
that about David night time working and
increasing
their internal
you know I don't know what the actual
taxi drivers feel about that because
we've not heard
they're silent but do what we'll do
practice like this I've invite you to
speak
I'd like to know your viewpoint on
what's what we've just discussed do you
need an uh an increase on your night
rate
yeah but I was I was here when yeah you
got your injuries because we decided
two or three years okay
that's fine
and and
pressure wise
you know
with the rank
you know you're sat on the right going
by this report for two or three hours
I'm not earning any money I mean
it's not good you know yeah yeah
[Music]
no okay
uh
[Music]
Field Center letter in I mean the only
thing is the good news is that with
respect to Chris we actually pay for the
survey because
to come back
and actually sort of told us what we
already know it is
the fuel that Steve might write me with
this monster living we wouldn't want him
to go in more physical and
um on top of that I think it's the fact
that it's so quite a belief in what that
survey is trying to say is obviously
maybe the money will be twice
and obviously long enough during the day
we've got a guaranteed because
they're going empty-handed yeah but uh
and obviously so the big concern you've
got is uh we haven't already got enough
overflow car marketing but but it's
actually we've got you know we've got
about seven parking places that usually
fit the Bitcoin taxis
um
certain
yeah
thank you interested the children speak
her friends
yeah on the puzzle bias letter saying
certain councils are asking for
deregulation I'm going to where that
came from I mean
I could certainly be against that given
the situation that's being described and
that wouldn't solve the problem
no no I mean there's one counselor um I
understand that a lot of concerns about
the fact that uh
[Music]
you know obviously it it kind of bush
would be values I met the amount of
homework it's not purely that taxi you
know I think you put the background for
the fact that anything that applied to
be a private higher driver if there's a
lot of fun work out there predominantly
the report says that we should serve the
bank which is
simply do and
um unfortunately a little bit like buses
you know we're always there exactly
where you need us
um and I was going to openly explain
that to uh
that's the only reason I'm interested
explaining the marketing so at that
yeah
it's not helpful to sort of like you
know put that sort of thing out there
and it falls along you know this yes
it's the cost of living devices
a lot of that is going on in there yeah
to the guys anxieties
um
what we're going to do yeah unless we
can vote on the two separate items if we
can first of all vote on 2v2 the two
available plates
um
the 49 plate limit for about three years
until we do the next survey of the
student loss increase yeah I'll propose
that as well
okay
by the way with the deregulation
yeah three years and no later they sort
of suggested attract a shelter and is
that something we can consider put on
the forward planet that has been rated
previously you know to leave it to
discuss at the Town Council
um whether it be funding available to
the Town Council but I'm not sure where
we're cutting with that stage now but
we're still on that one because um you
know with the adventure that happened
other things over to
um but it's something that will really
determine for what that the townhouse
oh right
okay so we're not just going to discuss
about the the increase that you're
saying the lifetime increase after what
we've heard um
no I've been alluded and particularly
the the increase
um
and based on their opinion as well I
don't know if it needs to improvise that
this statement No they're in this is key
we always want to do the job not us it's
too valuable
thank you
the third one
two again first okay thank you
yes so this report is looking for Google
from the connect sea to community
consultation exercise
um there's no legal requirements about
the policy but it's always good practice
to have a policy that's very important
the license holder again public housing
councilors as well when when having
decisions
the legislation K in in 2018
um white sweeping changes a lot of it
was very prescriptive so it was quite
straightforward but as we've implemented
and operated in the new legislation
there had been a few areas that are open
to interpretation
um so as a result of that we've decided
that it would be good practice to have a
policy
um so basically we're just seeking
approval at the moment to go after
consultation and then obviously once
we've had the consultation will come
back to the committee to perform an
approval the only thing that's
in addition to what we're doing already
posed in the policy is to undertake a
basic EDM check for applicants which
will determine if they have any previous
convictions relating with animals
cruelty or anything so it's good which
we don't do at the moment
um
other than that it's basically what
we're doing at the moment in the policy
so really it's just the proven to be
having a consultation having a policy
would that help us clamp down on things
we've got the legislation to do that
anyway the the key thing with the policy
is there's a few procedural aspects of
like a Heroes procedures the DBS checks
and things it's only guiding out little
sort of bits that it's just to make it
clearer to anything close to Christmas
yeah you know it's like you know
somebody opens a boot of this car and
he's got like a shared load of parties
for sale on the quick and I still
believe you and learn that yeah yeah I'm
sure it has yeah but we don't need it
you know we want to be pretty
then goes into place like K9 or you know
they end up with a problem then yes
this is just uh domestic or it's
property Farms or is it uh rescue
centers or it doesn't it doesn't apply
to rescue centers it's anything where
the public basically paid to have a
service so it's that if you agreed in
and you're selling puppies to the public
you need to be licensed in line with the
criteria if you have three or more
letters a year or you're operating a
business so you're having an income with
over a thousand pounds a year that's
that's why yeah
things are so expensive these days
basically the only way you would need a
license now is if you accidentally add
some puppies and you gave them away to
friends or whatever orders that are
giving me 10 pounds for that and I'll
you know that if it's
read it as a business it's like sensible
it also covers the boarding
establishments the dog and cat boarding
so if you go on holidays things like
that they're not to be licensed
um stable sustainables again where
they're hiring out their horses so when
they've been writing lessons yeah
they're purely delivering yards they
don't have to be but if they're actually
hiring those horses out and doing
lessons and things then they need to be
so we've got a couple of those yeah
we've got a rescue center out in our
neck the woods and it's applied for
planning permission they've got refuse
they've built it up anyway they're still
carrying on and
um they've got very certain effect
um a few DBS check on them because of
the prison sentences and that anyway I
mean yeah and they're not licensable and
and that's the that's the wrong thing
you know because they're they're asking
for donations so people are paying them
um 15 a month or whatever on Direct them
and then I feel that it needs that needs
to be listed as well but I do agree that
you know lots of uh
it with everything though it is down to
the enforcement and uh you know I've uh
um alluded the council to uh puppy Farm
but they've come back saying they're not
and basically they said how many of you
literally had all the ad3 but every
little it's occasion pounder dog every
every litter has been over five and uh
and uh but they got away with it well
I'm sure there's something we will have
to look at it yeah
the proof and the evidence to actually
go to court and take proper action
um
yeah it's got questions so this stuff's
basically horses dogs and cats that you
cover us I mean what about people
selling other sorts of animals
pet shops yeah included so they kind of
a
definitions and one of our resources are
you happy that you have those sources to
inspection yes we've got our
Environmental Protection Team because a
couple of officers we've had one officer
for some time we've now got a another
officer who's been trained out so we
have got support now as well so yeah
we're okay can I ask you how many any
convictions or you know investigation
therapy in recent years with no
prosecutions
we have done investigations that have
subsequently resulted in them being
licensed
um we've also got a graduating approach
to enforcement we then go straight in if
they're happy to work with us and we'll
work with them together license rather
than some occasions where we've taken a
couple of months or two or three months
we've worked with them to bring them up
to the standard and then they've been
able to apply for a license rather than
say no they're going to license you and
they go underground and we it's it's
better for all round really if we can
work with them and get them licensed
there are still gray areas you know it's
proven that thousand pounds and um
getting evidence that people they are
selling them because you have to get
people to come forward who are about to
bought those puppies
um so is is a tricky sometimes get the
evidence but we are does this also take
into account uh the inside Facebook
Marketplace
yeah just yeah that's that's a bit of a
mindfulness yeah and there's also
obviously we've got you can't go
trawling through websites so a rescue
centers
any rescue center that's doing it and
[Music]
wow
in that case then I I propose that we do
go to consultation on this certainly
about a second
yeah yeah
[Music]
[Music]
the end of the meeting